foreign
let's go to Jennifer and welcome to
Miami what's up Jennifer
hey what's up partying what are you up
to
oh you know still in this chilly weather
just a little bit just a little bit is
it chilly in Miami
I mean it's like 75.
the salt trucks are out driving around
no don't touchy it's like that's like a
balmy August day in the north all right
so what's going on
okay so I have the most wonderful
question for you I've been really
dealing with this um the past few years
how do I discuss
marital abuse
um with my children without putting
something on them without being you know
disrespectful to their father but also
being authentic I mean they were there
you know they know uh to an extent
um that things were different than maybe
some of their their friends uh home life
but I'm just I've really been at a loss
lately
how old are your kids
uh they range in age from 10 to 25. okay
um the self-contact with their dad
yes
they do yes now they do okay
um
what kind of abuse was it
um
I
was married for over two decades and I
ended up
working for three years
um it started off as kind of like a
emergency safety plan kind of thing when
I was still terrified to try to leave
again and then it ended up being more of
an escape plan with the local police
department and two different therapists
um obviously my children didn't know
that but um it was
pretty much everything
um and then add a little evil on top of
that I was thinking the other day if
there was an Aces score for being
married mine would be like a 13. if that
would be the problem so you know not to
be dramatic or anything no no no but um
so you got beat up a lot
um not initially
um but as the years progressed yes it
started
um the physical actually really started
when I was pregnant with my youngest and
um you know I have truly been crying out
to God in the middle of being told I was
going to be murdered okay
um
there was psychological abuse on top of
the physical abuse
yes and it has made it very challenging
um especially with my my older children
because
my character assassination started when
they were very very small
um you know things like who Do You Love
More mom or dad or if Mom and Dad ever
got a divorce
uh you're gonna go with Daddy right and
this is at a time when I didn't know at
the time that he was being unfaithful to
me again but
um and I had never ever divorce had
never even been uttered where anything
to do with my side of the family was
always very very bashed and obviously
isolated um it got to a point not gotcha
point it started
um but I had no frame of reference for a
healthy relationship
you know we're just very very isolating
but he's such a beautiful Charming
successful
intelligent giving man and so when he
started even realizing towards the end
like she's I was starting you know I was
learning some boundaries in how to
distance in a way
um he had started really going out of
his way to
um
say things about me in our very small
local community
um that would make anything that I said
maybe not believed or distrusted and
with our children he would always say
you're such a liar you're such a liar
just for everything and
um it was very interesting to you know I
was told at the end a lot of gaslighting
you know
um that
my unforgiveness of the past was what
was holding back our relationship that I
really was he thought I had mental
issues and if I ever left him that he
would insist on the psychological
evaluation that maybe I needed to be on
medication
it was a lot of not just
um severe physical but
um all the things that have made it very
confusing for my especially my older
children where they looked at me and
said I just don't know what to believe
and I had never tried to defend myself
because I didn't want to bring them in
the middle but I realized that he was
saying things
um and it you know really put a strain
on a relationship sure because I wasn't
saying anything and the other side was
saying a lot and 99 of it was a lie so
at 25 your 25 year old
either is showing the same
Psychopathology as their dad or is
beginning to put two and two together
she actually has she's my only daughter
she has quite severe uh intellectual
disabilities and
um she read through it all from the
beginning and it has taken a lot for her
to now even have
um relationship in a way he's been sober
for a little over a year and that's the
longest that I have seen
which I know sounds awful but in a lot
of ways it's so much scarier
um because he can be more conniving and
I I know this sounds better and I don't
mean it that way let me stop for a
second
uh how long have you all been divorced
it has been over three years
I can feel the terror that still pulses
through your veins
you listen listen you're unable to
literally unable to answer a yes or no
question
because
your brain starts churning so fast for
the 40 different ways I can use what you
just said against you and you got to
come up with another reason another
solution and a way to diffuse it in a
way to move it and push it let's push it
left it's okay but we're gonna do this
and you have to move like that
because your body recognizes one alarm
system and it's Terror
right you're one oh correct 100 I become
a politician how do I answer this
without getting into trouble
and listen that is the part that
um
like so to answer your question like
very very directly with adult children I
will answer questions honestly when they
ask
or if they're about to do something that
I think is going to get them hurt
okay
um
I will not go throwing grenades and I
will also preface it with this one
important thing kids know they are equal
part mom and dad and so when they find
out something evil about one of the
parents then they cannot help it but
internalize that so for therefore so am
I
right
and so all of those conversations have
to be prefaced with
um I will tell you about what happened
when or if Dad says you whatever or even
if you Circle back to your 21 year old
and said hey a year ago you said that
Dad told you that I was crazy and I had
mental health issues and all this
there's way more to this story and one
day when if you ever want to know I will
be I promise to be honest with you even
when it's hard
okay and leave it there
your 25 year old who struggles with
intellectual disabilities sometimes not
always folks who struggle with
intellectual disabilities become savants
at reading social cues oh my gosh you
yes you nailed it and so she may
struggle with reading she may struggle
with arithmetic yeah but God knows she
knows relationships because that's the
way her brain just had to evolve to
survive
yeah and she might not be able to put
her finger on it but she knows that
guy's not like I'm his body energy is
telling me something different than the
words coming out of his mouth and it's
disoriented right yes and he used does a
great job telling her that she's dumb or
that she's stupid or creating some world
where she can only exist with him
Fair
or it doesn't exist at all correct you
won't even acknowledge
there you go so here's because he
doesn't she doesn't play into that's
right uh it doesn't play his rules
doesn't play his game yes you still do
yes you're still participating yes and
it the greatest gift you can give your
children at this point is not a story or
a narrative that will come down the road
the greatest gift you can give your kids
is to begin healing
yes
and you haven't done that yet
I feel like I've come a really really
long way my
being there but I'm so grateful I've
done a lot of hard work I think what has
this has come up is my oldest son
um has expressed some like hurt and
frustration with me because I was dad's
biggest cheerleader
and he and and he's because he has
experienced
um The Mask slip when there wasn't
sobriety all the time and so for a very
short time just the way you said that's
so great when there wasn't sobriety all
the time when my husband was an abusive
violent drunk
well even after I divorced him I know I
know so yeah here's what will happen in
this please please please please please
please please please hear the the loving
spirit with which I'm about to say this
okay okay please please please because
I'm walking a dangerously thin razor and
I probably wouldn't bring this up if you
and I were in counseling in therapy
together for a couple of sessions
because this is too soon but I've only
got you for a few minutes okay oh no go
ahead I love it um
your child is right to ask you
why didn't you protect us
yes they're they are right to ask that
question and
as a terrified frightened
powerless person in a highly abusive
relationship
there's not an answer for that question
right yes yes that's what I have grieved
that is the conversation that I have had
at times or whether it was writing a
letter a couple times in person
specifically with my older children
possibly possibly both possibly writing
the letter and and but reading it I know
I I have done both okay I have
apologized to them
for not protecting them and I think they
need to hear you apologize to you
yeah because the way you are
communicating now you still don't
believe that you have needs or value I
can hear it in you even this call is how
can I fix their life
not recognizing that the greatest gift
you can give them is you anchoring into
something
firm anchoring into something into
bedrock
ex can you explain
when you are
in a committed highly abusive
relationship you're a kite in the wind
yes that is occasionally pulled down to
be set on fire or stomped on and then
sent back up into the air
and when you sever that relationship the
reason that relationship is so hard to
sever is you know that that's going to
cut that kite string and then you are
tossed to the wind and if you look at
the data women who leave abusive men
they're they're they fall into poverty
with higher rates they everything in
their life goes down and weirdly not
weirdly frustratingly it often Works
inversely for men the abuse of guidance
up better off financially ends up with a
better fill in the blank right right and
so you hang on because I don't know
where I end up if I cut this line
and you summoned The Bravery and the
courage and the strength
that millions of abused women before you
have summoned and you cut that line
and all of a sudden you realized you
were on the ground the whole time
I mean I agree and I also uh think that
one of the biggest
biggest things that I didn't know that I
had to learn was I mean I knew it in
inside of me instinctively
um leaving you know people would be like
what if someone gotta win why didn't why
don't you leave why don't you I mean he
cheats he does say all the things and
and it's because when you make that
decision or you even start to pull away
it's actually more dangerous for you for
such a time you know it's you appeasing
seems like a safer place for such a long
time until it isn't anymore because you
can't appease that's right that's right
as you know so it's a really a big deal
and I recently uh lost one of my sons he
was killed just a few months ago and uh
so I I had a lot of this resurface a lot
that I really thought I had worked
through because I've done a lot of hard
work
um well Jennifer Jennifer Jennifer you
lost a son
yes how old
he was almost 21 he was killed he didn't
pass right away he passed about a week
and a half after what happened
he there's a lot more to it than this
but essentially
um he was crossing the street after some
other things had happened his car was no
longer functioning to drive and
um three or four men in a car hit him on
the street and left him for dead
oh my gosh I'm so sorry have you had to
grieve this all by yourself
um no I've had a wonderful wonderful
gracious support system of
um some family and close friends that
have really stepped up it's been amazing
humans are awesome I've really been
grateful but
um I think with that all the things that
I hadn't done in a really long time like
wake up in the middle of the night from
bad dreams
um about my ex-husband or even just
feeling I think that as the numbness is
wearing off because like you have to be
numb for so long to survive and as you
you dethaw
I'm realizing how angry I am yes
and you're a lot you're allowed to be
angry
and you've never been allowed to be
angry before
correct but I don't want it to be
put on my children if you don't let them
know that you are angry
they will feel it on you and they will
blame themselves
or
they will in a perverse sideways way
try to do some reverse algorithm math
and be like well maybe Dad was right
yeah you have to tell them how
devastated you are
yeah how
just raged out angry you are
you have to
and you have to allow your body to
experience this
is grief
and you've had people walking alongside
you and bringing you casseroles and
showing up with you and take care of
your lawn and they've been really really
remarkable
yeah
but you gotta yeah my kids have
commented that
that hasn't happened for their father of
course and I don't know how to answer
that
he has chosen not to surround himself
with people who love him there we go
that's his choice
I'm sad for him but that's the choice
that he made yeah as often as you can
make moving forward conversations about
you
okay what you felt I didn't feel safe
why didn't you feel safe to your 15 year
old
it's adult conversations it was just a
scary time I was younger and I didn't
fully understand my own strength and I
didn't fully understand what being
married was like
I'll talk to you more about when you're
older to your 25 year old I was scared
because your dad told me he would murder
me
yeah
right you see the difference there
and I'm going to say some hard things
about your father I need you to look at
me and believe me when I say I do not
see any of this in you
yeah
you're an amazing young son young
daughter young whoever
um was the one who chose to stay
um with Dad full-time and he
would comment to me at times but Mom if
I leave he literally stepped into my
shoes the you know where walking in and
it you know Dad's threatening to kill
himself and all those things because he
realized as
people were detaching after so much time
like oh gosh I need to reel them back in
or that's what I'm assuming and um you
know that's been such the struggle is
that it's con I want to run in there and
grab my child and say
you can't have him not because I don't
want him to have relationship with his
father but because it's been so
devastating to watch my child
choose for or even be manipulated to
choose to stay when it's hurting him and
he even has said to me at times mom I've
I've wished at times that Dad was dead
not because I want him to die or hurt
but then he would be at peace and we
would be at peace and yet he still
chooses his father in so many ways I
feel so hurt like yeah
how old is he
he's 22.
saying something like your daddy's not
well
yeah oh for sure and I'm I it's it's
unbelievable to me the young man you are
that you love hurting people so well
absolutely
and anytime you want to come home
my door is always open for you
he knows but he could never do that but
it wouldn't be safe it's just saying it
again and saying it again and saying it
again okay and what I'll tell you is if
something is not safe
you talked about it earlier you they
start making plans and you start like
okay it's not safe here so we're gonna
have a like a strategy for calling the
cops for doing this for doing this for
doing this
if something isn't safe that's the Bell
that is the alarm system you got to get
out of that situation
your 22 year old son cannot be
responsible for an adult father he keeps
threatening to kill himself
he's not trained for that he doesn't
have the professional skills for that
he's too enmeshed in that relationship
he can't do it
and so I'm going to call 9-1-1 every
single time I'm gonna tell my son son
neither you or I are trained for this so
we're just gonna start calling 911 every
single time every single time we're
calling
because we can't handle it and if Dad
says if you call 911 again I'm gonna
well Dad now I'm really gonna call him
because I don't I don't have any other
play I don't know I don't know how I can
help you
you're so oh man there's so much here
Jennifer
um
so much here
um
I think the safest not safest the
smartest play right now for you is to
spend some time grieving your son
I want you to write your son a letter
and tell them how much you miss him
and actually I want you to call
um an evening together with all your
kids here as as the holidays are
approaching and I know this call is
going to be aired after New Year's but
it's right before Christmas when we're
when we're on this call I want you to
invite your kids over for an evening and
I want you all to write your son their
brother who passed away a letter
let them know how much they miss him
I don't know how heartbroken they are
and I want you all to share that grief
together as a family
and if you need to have one or two
friends over because your family isn't
doesn't have the practice of shared
grief that's great if you have a
counselor you want to bring over great
but I think y'all should all write a
letter and read them together
and just notice that empty seat there at
the table we miss brother
and then as questions come up
with your adult kids
again let them know I don't see this in
you but
um I was young and I was scared and I
didn't know where to turn next and
I'm sorry that you went through that and
I'm also sorry that I experienced that
and here we are
what we can control is what comes next
and what nobody can ever take away is
how much I love you to the Moon and back
and the moon and back and the Moon and
back
foreign
call anytime anytime and
um I'll walk alongside you thank you for
being brave